[Music]
and smart for lazy news submitted by
Czech Republic loves JK oh you guys used
to watch our strong research suggests
being lazy is a sign of high
intelligence BAM I'm aware this one
before so every time you call me lazy
boys because I'm [ __ ] smart I never
call you lazy are you talking about
anything [ __ ] oh yeah hey your mom calls
me lazy oh yeah I hate these articles
you're lazy yeah why I don't know cuz
it's just like a negative thing but like
they just try to justify it let me hear
the [ __ ] read you know what's all
smart doesn't mean successful exactly so
what's wrong with that
uh it's lazy and smart yeah you're
useless I gotta hear this article
because I kind of do it just almost like
if you're jealous you're smart so just
take a random like negative traits and
then just adding like the tongue lazy
not negative and then they're gonna go
the route Steve Jobs saying that she
likes to hire lazier people because I
think of Steve Jobs someone like Sarah
Lee the people because they can figure
out ways to seem lazy subjective to be
more efficient it you're thinking
disabled not like handicapped disabled
I'm talking about people with low
self-esteem that don't [ __ ] do
anything with life that's that's very
different from lazy what's the
definition of low would define lazy
today everyone has a different
definition amazing in this study it's
supported the idea that people that have
a high IQ are more likely to engage in
thought versus games versus versus those
who are more active core active people
on they need to simulate their minds
with exercise because they tend to like
get bored easily see I could stimulate
my mind doing shut up that's what does
that part make sense to me because my
definition of lazy is when you know
you're something you gotta do and you
don't do it no no yeah that's my
deafness
no that's another definition the late
late lazy in this way is loophole II
exact that's more yeah that's the
efficient thing that I was talking about
right yeah but that's why I'm lazy is
because I don't want to do it the hard
way
yeah I tell my mom I'm like she's like
all you create a good system or whatever
and show like get impressed my guess was
I'm [ __ ] lazy so I'm always trying to
like find that fastest way to do she
call yourself does not have any any
stupid it might messing my destination
ratio is more of attitude so doesn't
matter if you're doing a smart way or
the convoluted way it's the attitude
where there's this thing that has to be
done and you're just not doing it it
smells like a [ __ ] old man's Cologne
well that's the axe break from the
bathroom I sprayed it sorry go on
yeah so you guys could question the
study because it is a small pool where
they did get a group of students and you
will ask the questionnaire which would
have questions like I really enjoy a
task that involves coming up with new
solutions to problems or statements like
I only think as hard as I have to and
like based on those statements it's more
of like how much do you agree with this
a statement and how much do you disagree
with the statement and so after getting
those results they picked 30 people that
I consider thinkers and 30 people that
is considered non thinkers and they
monitored them they monitor them for
four meters for seven days dumbass you
want to be a part of this project and
troopers [ __ ] communal and they monitor
these people for seven days to see what
their activities and that would their
activities are and so they realize that
those who have like a high IQ or who's
constantly engaged in their own thoughts
like they don't tend to be as active as
those like who gets bored easily and so
they're things like oh this is a very
interesting study because then you know
is not to say that those who have high
IQ can't work out it's just that we want
to bring more awareness to those who
have IQ that you know you could always
kind of workout in now you can always
plan a workout ending I can but I have
that surgery thing or not so they're
saying that it
there is achill - yes yes physical
laziness that's different from [ __ ]
being a lazy sack of [ __ ] that likes to
just chill yeah I all see something
completely different
so physical business just means like
someone that takes the elevator versus
the stairs without the time it's just
more like somebody just isn't acting not
physically active and they don't find a
Joy's in physical activity or whatever
but this study is a sack of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] lying sack of why is it why why
why why because it's only got a small
sample size it's not a real scientific
study and how the [ __ ] do you define
laziness in the first place that [ __ ]
that's just a construct of [ __ ]
culture that's not that's the you how do
you [ __ ] what do you what is lazy and is
it is it positive or negative
my dad's design laziest person on earth
its person it's just subjective dude
because in some cultures they value that
[ __ ] it's not called laziness it's just
called [ __ ] spending time with family
and relationships or like doing [ __ ] in
our world
capitalism is king right so like doing
keeping busy all that [ __ ] working all
the time
that's what skiing that's like oh that's
great you're doing a great [ __ ] job
but if you go to another society they're
like what the [ __ ] you work so much why
don't you spend enough time with family
for us we're just like oh that's lazy
we're not making money we're just
relaxing all day eating chips and
talking with our family so I think it's
it's a [ __ ] a load of sack of [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] article I'll rip you up
if you were paper Oh since if they went
from a human to paper no yeah I just
think your [ __ ] needs to get done you
don't do it so even like let's say you
haven't seen your dad in a long time
you're supposed to go see him you don't
do it that's being rated you yeah if
there's like after a party and there's
all this food on a [ __ ] table and
you've been lazy together as a group
but you don't clean it up together that
lazy that's Stacey but I love being lazy
by the way much this is being fun yeah
the lazy is life I gotta do this but
okay yeah this the study that they
actually did like it just
wasn't it wasn't selling it to me
personally because they're just saying
yeah like throughout the week like they
just saw that the stinkers that the
stinkers warrants easily active and then
like the non thinkers were very
inaudible but then but then on the
weekends there was like no activity so
it's just like how is this like oh very
you know what this [ __ ] this is exactly
what you were saying before bard like I
just read this quick title out of
nowhere right it was one of those little
BuzzFeed [ __ ] [ __ ] it goes 10 reasons
why insecure guys are the best people to
date shut up [ __ ] are you talking about
you dumb [ __ ] I would like to meet you
in person so I could [ __ ] Riverdance
on your toes you [ __ ] [ __ ] people
are just like putting out things just to
say things now you know I mean it's
great to be with the insecure person
because it showed that they're very
sensitive yet too sensitive [ __ ]
that's the problem [ __ ] 5 reasons why
you should never get an oil change yes
like a craziest [ __ ] ever now and then
they repeat they'd say they changed the
first reason it's like 3 different ways
to have make 3 more ways 10 reasons why
you should never brush your teeth if I
put this but yeah it's just ridiculous
dude like come on man
there is a non showering movement going
on Oh for real no I need a shower
showering it's like my mini vacation
yeah I feel cleanse at the end of the
day I need to take that hot shower
because it makes me feel like all the
stress web [ __ ] off my body yeah yeah
you bring that up because I just read an
article or I just saw it the title of an
article and I thought was crazy I'm
saying that girls so the myths are leave
enough for me why you shouldn't wipe
your butt after you poop no so they
would tell girls like oh if you don't
want to dry out your sculpt or people
against the mainly girls took this
information you don't want to drop your
sculpt take a shower every other day but
then now they're saying oh you're not
taking enough showers except what though
well what is it not enough shower is
argument I didn't really think is all
like digest religion I think it's just
like dependent on how oily you are as a
person
that's why you didn't care to everybody
use this girl as an example I won't say
her name but she's a friend from
Sacramento this little [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] oily because her friends don't
don't take showers as often because
they're dry as [ __ ] and she goes oh
that's what girls are supposed to do I'm
like no you little [ __ ] egg roll
watch yourself
and like where I'm talking about we went
camping right and I saw this [ __ ]
playing with the fire other you bought
the light the [ __ ] up to a greasy and
smug step the [ __ ] away from that
campfire she grabbed the last paper she
[ __ ] stays that [ __ ] yeah dude she
grabs a paper bag to the [ __ ] turn
see through I do want to try something
though I do want to try for a year
living in the wild like camping everyday
eating just the food from that area
not showering and just having my body
covered in dirt and seeing how I feel
react and smell after a year a year yes
I am God I just want to see what that
feels like like Jessica's not going to
let you so I'm eating I'm eating just
everything from the land and then my
body is just covered in all this stuff
and maybe there's a river there I can
bathe but no soap nothing it's just
all-natural and I want to see how my
body turns out because maybe some of the
smells coming from eating is definitely
our time yeah but if I'm eating [ __ ]
sequoia tree all day and squirrel you're
not I mean look I've got food he can't
wait to be a home oh no it might be an
easier way instead of spending a whole
year is just smell a monkey because that
[ __ ] been living in the same
habitat you want to live in
oh he's supposed to us it's like our
disguise smells like urine and poop food
smell the mug your smell like a really
nice guy Tammy go back I got lies
hey guys thanks for watching our last
episode did you love it I know you did
so make sure to give this video a big
thumbs up and to watch more videos you
can watch them off with you
[Music]